my dear brothers and sisters may Allah
bless you all I just want to speak about
the issue of boycotting so there's two
opinions among the scholars some scholar
said you can boycott individually you
want to boycott the companies that are
supporting the zist who are killing our
brother and
S protect our brothers and sisters and S
said boy cting to have a great impact he
has to go back to the leaders he has to
go back to the leaders so if you follow
the first opinion which you can which
you can do individually
if you follow it you cannot force the
other people to follow your opinion and
vice versa likewise you cannot start
doubting people's IM based upon
boycotting like some people I met they
boycott but don't pray that will add him
to Jenna but if brother prays and he
doesn't have to be perfect and he
boycott and he's doing for the sake of
Allah may Allah reward him okay so also
I want to mention there is a clip when
someone clearly took it out of my video
which was longer than hour on Tik Tok
say Shi is mocking people are boycotting
that is a lie I was speaking about
people coming to me say I have to
boycott such such a company when himself
is using uh Instagram okay the owner is
a z supporter all right because when you
start using the apps he's making money I
give you something if you want to really
boycott and it's going to have impact on
the Western
Government come out and speak to the
American government to the Muslims
America stop paying taxes America just
gave 14 billion to the
that money is coming from where from
taxes money all right so alhamd I
mention if you want to do it for the
sake of Allah boting your for the
opinion that individually you can do it
aldah Allah reward you but you cannot
start doubting people's IM because they
don't accept that opinion and vice versa
we ask Allah to Aid our brothers and
sister and to protect them and to give
them victory over their
enemies